next former CNN correspondent Siobhan
Darrow and former photojournalist
Deborah kapal Caen Cogan talked about
their careers as war reporters ms Kogan
is author of shudder babe about her
adventures as a young photojournalist in
Afghanistan and Romania and Siobhan
Darrow's new book is called flirting
with a danger detailing her 15 years
covering Russia Chechnya and Northern
Ireland during this hour and a half
event they discussed their quest for
impartiality their lives on the front
lines of a war zone and their need to
eventually leave their jobs
there you go
that's a little bit better welcome to
Olsen's books and records for DC's
largest an oldest independent bookstore
and I'm really happy to see such a
wonderful turnout here tonight and thank
you all very much for coming and
supporting our events and your local
independent bookstores I just briefly
briefly before we get to our guests for
this evening I wanted to give you an
update on a few of the people who are
going to be coming to the store in the
upcoming week we do have more fliers and
information on the side which you
probably can't get to right at the
moment but we also have an email update
so if you want to sign up to get emails
of events going on at the different
Olson stores please feel free to do so
before you go on Tuesday February 12th
at 7 p.m. at the store Metro Center
Peter Bergen will be here his book he'll
be discussing his book holy war ink
inside the secret world over savasana
bin Laden he's won the future analyst
that has actually spoken and interviewed
face to face with Osama bin Laden so I
think that might be a pretty interesting
evening for a lot of people he has a
perspective that a lot of other people
won't be able to get bring to the issue
on February 13th at 7 p.m. at this store
James Hirsch will be here discussing his
book riot and remembrance which is about
the Tulsa race war and the legacy left
over from one of the nation's bloodiest
racial struggles and that was that
happened in 1921 so I think that'll be a
really interesting evening for history
buffs and anybody else interested in in
in these issues also on the 14th we have
two events on Thursday the 14th Tricia R
Thomas will be here discussing her new
book the Napoli ever after that'll be at
12:30 in the afternoon here that's an
event that'll be occurring in the back
of the store and that evening at 7:00
p.m. we're really excited because
Miranda Carter will be here reading and
discussing her biography of Anthony
Blunt and that's all I'm gonna do to
take up your time I'm not
I keep you waiting our guests we're all
very excited to have these women at the
store tonight especially I think it's
really cool for those women of those of
us who always have aspired to do
something a little bit more exciting
with our lives and step outside of our
own sphere and see the world
Deborah Copiague and Cogan is here she's
going to be discussing her book shudder
babe we're very excited to have her and
also Siobhan Darrow for flirting with
disaster flirting with disaster thank
you yeah thank you all for coming first
let me tell you the real title of my
book it's flirting with danger you know
as I watched the war in Afghanistan on
television I really feel for my
colleagues out there because I know how
difficult it is to cover a war under
those circumstances I know how hard it
is just to find food to stay warm to
stay out of danger
let alone how to tell the story and much
of the time that I was out there doing
that as a correspondent for CNN for
almost a decade I really felt like I was
numb and I didn't know why I was there
and I didn't know I didn't want to be
there I don't know it really wasn't
until I never wanted to be a war
correspondent I just stumbled into it
and it wasn't until I sat down to write
the book that I was really able to make
sense of what led me there I was born in
Belfast my mother is a our enjoyment
my father was an American Jew of Russian
extraction we moved to America when I
was very young and my parents had their
own kind of mini war zone so I grew up
on some level comfortable in conflict
and I didn't my father died when I was
in high school and I didn't really get
to know him
and I found when I went to college I was
drawn to Russian Russian studies and I
think in many ways it was a search for
my lost father and I'm going to begin
reading to you tonight from chapter 2
when I in Moscow when I went there as a
university student
I met Dima in my quest for a decent meal
as a visiting University student in
Russia in 1980 I was obsessed with
finding food I lived in a bleak poorly
heated dormitory on the outskirts of
Moscow and found it hard to adjust to
the challenge of day-to-day life in the
Soviet Union it was still five years
before Gorbachev and perestroika
appeared on the scene the food was
unbearable the cafeteria served gray
sausages for breakfast lunch and dinner
the thoroughly cooks didn't seem to care
but then they snarled at us when we
returned our plates meals uneaten out on
the streets in the drudgery so well
known to the average Soviet working
men's eateries offered soup that tasted
like dirty dishwater with a hunk of
gristle and a rotten potato on the side
some of the other American students
appeased their hunger by befriending
Marines at the American Embassy and
getting invited there for specially
imported hamburgers others of us hungry
for the true Russian experience toughed
it out that meant wandering the streets
of Moscow ever searching for food it
brought me adventure even when my
stomach remained empty I explored
Moscow's extraordinary museums
overflowing with cultural riches of ads
our Espace
I love the parks full of monuments
gleaming statues of cosmonauts heading
into space and muscled Soviet women
workers toiling toward a bright
socialist future I ventured into Russian
bath houses where naked strangers engage
in the peculiarly pleasant experience of
pouring buckets of hot water over one
another and beating each other with
eucalyptus branches we were all equal in
the bath houses Russians would say to me
one day I got lucky a fellow student
took me to the home of a fashion
designer named Slava who lived in an
elite apartment in the center of Moscow
on Marx Engel Street in contrast to the
daily drudgery outside there was a
hidden colorful world of privilege and
comparative luxury it was my first peek
at the dual world that existed in the
Soviet Union then at Slava's there were
always beautifully dressed people and
delicacies like French cognac and
imported chocolate Slava's was a bastion
of comfort in another way
gloomy environment on one of my early
visits I noticed a young Russian man
with enormous sad brown eyes
his name was Dima and he was the most
handsome Russian I'd ever seen he was
learning fashion photography in order to
immortalize Slava's creations
he often entertained us with songs and
jokes I fell for demon the moment he
opened his mouth and started singing I
thought I'd never heard a more sensual
voice and could listen to him for hours
It was as if he just stepped out of one
of the 19th century Russian novels I'd
been studying dark and melancholic he
sang cossack ballads and made fun of a
regime that didn't have much of a sense
of humor all of the harshness and
bleakness of russia's soul reverberate
adorable tone his favorite pastime was
singing renditions of lydia vysotsky a
banned russian singer whom nobody was
officially allowed to listen to but
everyone secretly loved on the
anniversary of Assad Sookie's death
Russians would congregate with bootleg
recordings of his verses which were
reminiscent a Bob Dylan and gave voice
to the dreariness of average Soviet
workers lives in parks people would
gather singing the outlawed words
posting the lyrics to trees in tribute
Dima introduced me to many underground
cultural heroes opening a spiritual
world as rich and forbidden as the food
at Slava's the authorities proudly
displayed Lenin's pickled body in Red
Square solemnly marching schoolchildren
and tourists passed his hallowed resting
place yet Dima showed me how ordinary
people discretely paid homage to their
forbidden icons he took me to the grave
of Boris Pasternak the banned Russian
poet and author of dr. Zhivago where
devotees would gather and recite his
contraband verses aloud to one another
Dima also took me to a downtrodden
Moscow alley where literary pilgrims
made the journey to another shrine the
one-time home of Mikhail Bulgakov author
of the Master and Margarita it was a
band classic work about the devil
turning up in Moscow and causing havoc a
thinly disguised allusion to Stalin
ba-gawk-oh fans painted the hallways of
the old apartment block with passages
and figures from his book the
authorities constantly painted over the
graffiti but Bo Gaucho's admirers always
returned to keep their hero a lie
the only way they could I delighted in
their subtle defiance I love this hidden
world and I fell in love with Dima
the truth is I loved Russia I was hooked
as soon as I stepped out into the
cobblestones of Red Square and caught my
first glimpse of st. Basil's Cathedral
with it's colorfully painted gingerbread
cupola so magical it looked plucked out
of a fairy tale on the other side of the
square was the solemn somber modern
Soviet tomb encasing Lenin it all
clashed yet coexisted the lack of
distractions of capitalism heightened
the appreciation of whatever small
unexpected pleasures life doled out some
Cuban bananas on sale outside the metro
stop or a plastic cigarette lighter from
the West could make someone's day in
those days Russia had a genuineness of
spirit born of hardship and a sense of
community Russians would always share
what little they had with one another
Bosco was cold and severe on the surface
but the dismal totalitarian sameness
couldn't contain the warmth and
earthiness of its complex soul it was
refreshing to someone brought up in New
Jersey in the 70s in a culture of
shopping and consumerism the Soviet
Union was giant unruly chaotic and in
constantly in conflict with itself
nothing worked it was full of tragedy it
repelled me and at the same time
attracted me just as my Russian blooded
father did Russia felt like one giant
dysfunctional family I was perfectly at
home there as in any dysfunctional
family one puts on a brave front no
matter how bad it is inside Russia for
many years pretended that its Armed
Forces were a real threat to the West
when it couldn't even feed its soldiers
I could relate to this way of being
tough on the outside and a fragile
quivering wreck within I've been
operating like that for years
one day the chaos couldn't be hidden
anymore and the Soviet Union fell apart
I would have my own unravelling as well
well things progressed with Dima in a
way that I never could have imagined I
loved him but I didn't know if he loved
me or my passport so right before my
visa ended and I was going to go back to
America he proposed and I said yes I was
young I was 20
deema had neglected to tell me that his
mother worked for a military
installation so the Soviet Union
wouldn't let him out even with an
American wife so this was back at during
the Reagan administration when we were
called the divided spouses and there
would be superpower summits where they'd
get together and they talk about arms
control and the Soviet withdrawal from
Afghanistan and the divided spouses this
handful of cases with spouses that we
couldn't get out of the Soviet Union it
took until Gorbachev came along and
perestroika for them to finally give him
an exit visa but by then our marriage
was in tatters and in the meantime I'd
gotten a job at CNN and that was back in
Atlanta when CNN was in a plantation an
old plantation and the other networks
made fun of it called a chicken noodle
Network I got hired as a tape logger for
$9,000 a year and I worked my way up
from the bottom of the barrel and had a
great time even had a fling with the
boss and eventually got sent back to
Moscow as a producer and it was
wonderful covering Russia trying to
explain the oddities and complexities to
the one-time enemy and the Soviet Union
fell apart I never wanted to be a war
correspondent I didn't even know what a
flak jacket was but the country fell
apart and civil war broke out and so I
all of a sudden became a war
correspondent and I'm gonna read to you
I was in Russia for almost five years
and I spent a lot of time in Chechnya
and I'm gonna read to a little bit from
a chapter called dancing warriors after
one too many trips to Chechnya we lived
like animals the way most people live in
a war we didn't wash our hair for weeks
we had to squat to relieve ourselves
wherever we could in the sub-zero
temperatures and bombed out buildings
our on the roadside we managed only a
few hours sleep a day we ate chocolate
bars or crackers or whatever we could
carry with us in our pockets surviving
for days without a real meal but we were
under pressure
to feed the network 24 hours a day it
seemed there was no news to speak of in
the rest of the world so our producers
were extra hungry for news from Chechnya
and our pictures were riveting
journalists don't often get such graphic
pictures of warfare close-up shots of
helicopter gunships and tanks firing
triage on the front lines the network's
thirst was unquenchable never able to
drink enough from the trough of human
suffering I woke up each morning with
dread I was exhausted my clothes were
filthy I knew I smelled when Christmas
Eve came I was depressed it was my worst
Christmas ever that night I felt
determined to do something mad to remind
me that there was a sane world outside
this one I hooked up one of our suitcase
sized satellite phones generally used
for news emergencies and called l.l.bean
at $20 a minute the American operator
put me on hold and then wanted me to
call back because the line was bad I
yelled at her fumbling in the dark for
flashlights to read off my credit-card
number so that I could order a teddy
bear as a present for my first nephew I
needed to feel some connection to this
new life however distant one day during
our drive into Grozny we came upon a
grisly scene a shopping street had just
been hit by Russian bombers it was next
to a bridge which must have been what
the planes had been aiming at the
Bombers might have missed their target
but they succeeded in their general
mission of causing terror and panic
several civilians were killed and
everyone was running away searching for
shelter but when bombs fall from above
nowhere feels like shelter and you feel
as vulnerable as a scurrying ant
it's a helpless feeling much worse than
being fired on from the ground by now
our cameramen had gone back to Berlin
and had been replaced by a woman Mary
she was about 5 foot 2 skinny and
fearless we went closer to survey the
damage bodies were scattered in the pack
snow which was stained with blood and
soot life had stopped in an instant a
woman still clutching her shopping bag
lay motionless her head no longer
attached a burly moustached man was
slumped over the wheel of his car no
longer hearing the wail of the horn
fires raged in the snowy wreckage of
people's
homes nearby if I survive this day I
promised myself I would never sleepwalk
through another day in my life I told
Mary that if we had enough footage we
should leave the Russian bombers had
missed the bridge the first time but
they might come back just then we heard
the sound of planes headed for us my
camera woman was still thinking about
getting that perfect shot and didn't
want to move I knew what was going on a
strange thing happens when you look
through a camera lens the image is so
vivid to the naked eye are in fact black
and white to the cameraman somehow
muting their impact just as were numbed
by the violence we see on television
nightly the photographers intent on
collecting their images are severed
emotionally from what they see when they
look through their viewfinders they
forget that they're just as vulnerable
as their subjects I could see the blood
in an instant I imagined my own body
lying like a husk shocked of its life I
pictured my hair matted with blood and
my family's horror when they got news of
my death I yelled at Mary to leave but
still she was reluctant the pull of
those dramatic pictures was too strong
finally I yanked on her arm and we ran
for cover in a nearby building the
planes flew by firing at other targets
life-and-death decisions over a picture
we made them all the time it seemed
crazy I was relieved to get out of there
thinking that I'd beaten the odds one
more time well a few more trips to
Chechnya and I'd had enough of the war
in Chechnya was particularly horrible
because there was no UN monitoring the
situation no medicine some frontier it
was a medieval war and I I needed to get
out of there so I asked CNN to send me
to London I thought I'd be able to have
a saner life there but no sooner had I
unpacked my bags then the IRA ceasefire
broke out and I was packed off to
Belfast and which was interesting for me
because I was from there but I hadn't
realized that the London Bureau for CNN
was such a fire station so wherever
trouble broke out I was running around
from one crisis to another so I finally
after three years there realised that I
needed to leave
profession I was in my late 30s and I
wanted to find a life have a family life
and I couldn't find any balance so I
decided to move to Los Angeles and write
a book but it was much harder to break
free of that life the excitement of that
kind of life than I'd ever imagined and
when the war broke out in Kosovo
I almost got sucked back in and I'm
gonna read you just one more section
here when Kosovo flared up something
drew me back in I watched NATO planes
send wave after wave of missile attacks
on the Serbs I couldn't turn off the TV
I found myself crying as I watched I
couldn't stop crying I cried for all the
times I've gone into villages and
interviewed refugees crammed 20 or 30
into a room I felt a powerful urge to go
there wanting to help tell their story
to the world I felt guilty sitting on my
sofa immobilized not doing anything I
was enraged by the US coverage of the
war which demonized the Serbs in an over
simplistic way mindlessly repeating NATO
jargon about morality I wanted to yell
it doesn't matter who's right and who's
wrong people are suffering I wanted a
chance to get in front of the cameras
again to describe the trauma of Albanian
refugees crossing the mountains cold and
afraid after being driven from their
homes or talk about the Serb in a black
woollen mask who had knocked on the door
and ordered the Albanians out pain
beneath the surface anger I could
explain that he hadn't been born bad
that I might have been even been to the
village his family was driven from where
his grandmother probably died in a
concentration camp run by Croatian
fascists and he had been weaned on
stories about the cruel Croats and
Albanians I knew I couldn't go back
there my time had passed and yet I felt
so drawn to it because it had been my
life for so long carpeting breaking news
like that and pitching in with CNN in a
crisis as I watched with tears streaming
down my face I thought I might as well
be there because I can't turn off the TV
I was mesmerised trapped by the feelings
of images stirred up in me the fear the
sense of futility of feeling like a
coward to sit and weep and not to
anything I picked up the phone to call
CNN to volunteer to go then panic
gripped my neck I didn't want to go I
didn't want to leave my sofa I didn't
want to see anymore I turned off the TV
I was like a junkie for whom the only
thing that will make her better is the
very thing that hurts her most there I
was frozen on the couch with the phone
in one hand feeling so terrible and
repelled by what I saw it's so drawn to
the violence in the crisis the only
thing that would break my paralysis I
thought would be to go I dialed the
number but hung up before anyone
answered this isn't my war I thought I
need to fight my own battle I'm like an
alcoholic on the wagon about to take a
drink I can't go there again
I remembered a house I'd visited once
with my camera crew it almost doesn't
matter where because I've been to that
house so many times in so many villages
we pulled up and knocked on the door
we'd driven past a stream of people some
of them on foot lugging hastily packed
suitcases others piled into tractors
with their clothes a few pots and pans
and family photos stepped into sheets
families uprooted in moments trudging
through the mud and snow and not sure
where they were going they walked slowly
their eyes blank with fear the children
held on tightly to their parents hands
the door opened to a crowded one-room
house 20 people were now living in a
place hardly big enough for two sharing
one bathroom and sleeping huddled on the
floor it was the home of a farmer and I
marveled at his humanity
I saw sadness and generosity in the eyes
of this man who took in 15 of the tired
arrivals his wife baking flat bread to
feed the hunk to feed the hungry
strangers
I interviewed a scared young mother who
didn't know where her husband was she
didn't know how she'd feed her children
or where they'd go next
she said she hoped to go home soon but I
knew better I had seen her so many times
before in so many places I just come
from her village and I'd seen what the
soldiers were doing there maybe that if
in her house burning the true extent of
what she just endured might take years
to absorb she might no longer have a
home to go back to I'd also seen her
husband many times he was no longer the
farmer who got up before sunrise to work
the fields to feed her and her Troy
now we hid in the hills with the other
men and used his rifle to take aim at
his enemy she might never see him again
I was touched by this mother who thought
to grab her son's teddy bear as they ran
from their home but I knew it wouldn't
be enough to comfort the boy or make him
ever forget what happened he would grow
up hating and yearning to return home
with vengeance in his heart it was
unbearable this misery and cruelty and
terror that I saw for only now could I
see it only now while watching it on TV
thousands of miles away I was safe in my
home and I felt their helplessness I
knew what it was like to be small and
scared I knew I couldn't go back into
war zones my armor was no longer in
place and I had no more stomach for war
which always seemed to be about the same
thing nobody ever wins it never works
whether an army is defeated or
victorious the wounds to the soul are
the same well I did manage to break my
addiction and I'm leading a much quieter
more peaceful life now but I feel it's
it's it's just time to turn this kind of
work over to the younger braver and more
energetic souls out there I mean it's
incredibly important especially in a
free society that someone's out there
chronicling especially in a time of war
but my story does have a happy ending
but I'll leave you to read about that
and I'm going to turn things over to Deb
thank you
this book came out a year ago in
hardback
and when I was trying to decide what's
read for my last book tour well-meaning
friends and colleagues and family
members said you know Deb that first
chapter about Afghanistan well nobody
really knows about Afghanistan so you
might as well just skip that what a
difference a year makes hmm
I will read from the chapter about
Afghanistan I think I'm gonna move this
cuz can you guys hear me okay I'll read
about the read from the chapter about
Afghanistan and then after that I will
read from and afterward I wrote the only
thing you need to know about this
because the name comes up is a man named
Pascale was the boyfriend I had in Paris
who brought me to Afghanistan told me he
was gonna take me inside with him and
then abandoned me and that's why I ended
up traveling by myself
so without further ado there's a war
going on and I'm bleeding an unfortunate
situation to be sure but considering
it's 2:00 a.m. fresh snow is falling and
I'm squished in the back of an old army
truck with a band of Afghani freedom
fighters who to avoid being bombed by
the Soviet plane circling above have
decided to drive without headlights
through the Hindu Kush mountains over
unpaved icy roads laced with landmines
it's also one without obvious remedy I
mean what am I supposed to do ask the
driver to pull over for a sec so I can
squat behind the nearest snow bank to
change my tampon I don't think so it's
February 1989 I'm 22 years old my toes
are so cold they are not so much mine
anymore as they are tiny miscreants
inside my hiking boots refusing to obey
orders in my lap hopping atop my thighs
as my truck as the truck lurches as my
body shivers
so it's a sturdy canvas donkey bag
filled with Nikon's and Kodachrome film
which I'm hoping to use to photograph
the pull out of the Soviet troops from
Afghanistan actually I have no idea how
to shoot a pullout from Afghanistan
though this is my second story as a
professional photojournalist I'm still
not clear on what it is photojournalist
actually do in a real war I look over at
Hashim who's rearranging blankets
knapsacks and boxes of ammunition to
clear more legroom on the crowded truck
bed he Yanks my maroon nylon backpack
from the center of the pile fills in the
newly empty space with a green metal box
mimes can I sit on this while pointing
at my backpack and when I nod yes he
wedges it into a corner and plops his
180 pound rump or right on top of it a
gentle crunching sound ensues followed
almost immediately by the smell of
rubbing alcohol [ __ ] my mind races to
try to call what else besides that
bottle of alcohol I packed in that
outside zippered pocket then I remember
my box of Tampax my one and only box of
Tampax
well now I'm [ __ ] oblivious Hashim
slowly inhales a Winston cigarette and
needs his amber worry beads through his
ragged fingers trained as a journalist
he's the one Afghani among my 47 escorts
who actually speaks a few key english
phrases such as food soon danger stay in
cave and toilet time miss Debra
but even though I know he will probably
understand me if I say please get off my
bag he definitely won't understand
because my tampons are exploding and
because please get off my bag sounds
sort of rude and because the squishy
backpack does look like a comfy place to
sit while all of us are scrunched
together on the back of this rickety old
truck heading God knows where and
because my hygiene woes do not hold a
candle to the miseries of jihad I say
nothing besides I'm covered from head to
toe in an electric blue burqa an Islamic
veil worn like a Halloween ghost costume
which tends to hinder communication not
only does it muffle my speech it makes
it impossible to guess for example that
underneath all this rayon under my shiny
blue ghost costume I cannot stop crying
so um the truck breaks down and we try
all night long to repair it and with no
luck so we ended up just abandoning it
and walking to where we had to go we
spend the next eight hours trekking
through knee-deep snow in a single-file
line and scurrying along as the Soviet
plane circle a head the mountain range
taunts us never seeming to get any
closer I'm exhausted and famished on the
verge of hypothermia but my major
problem is the burqa not only is the
rayon too thin to keep my head warm the
stupid thing keeps slipping down
tripping me making me blind how in God's
name or in Allah's name do Afghani women
deal with these ridiculous things we
women are cursed
never mind the blood in the mess that I
can deal with I'm talking about the fear
of female sexuality pure and not so
simple what is it about our bodies that
scares men so makes them to take such
extreme measures to put us in our places
if they're not stopping us on the
streets and the supposedly enlightened
parts of the world to whistle grab their
crotches lick their tongues between open
fingers yell obscenities our proposition
us with erect bananas I like most women
speak from a deep well of experience
here then they're hiding us under burkas
or veils
other parts of the world so that they
won't be tempted to do so I yanked the
burka off my head and throw it on the
ground no more I yell to Hashim which
causes all the men to stop and stare I
look around me I know it's dangerous to
be out of disguise but under the current
circumstances I could care less Wow I
think what freedom to see the world once
again to gaze at that beautiful jagged
gigantic imposing soaring ice-capped
mountain range in the distance put on
says Hashim no I say I won't put on he
repeats this time more slowly I stand my
ground
no he's dangerous he says I say I know
so make me a man sorry sorry
screwing up the sound
sorry about that for a moment the
situation is tense Hashim stares at me
at a loss for words some of the other
Mujahideen whispered to each other point
at me gesticulate I was told by
countless Mujahideen groups back in
Peshawar that as a woman I would not be
able to accompany their soldiers inside
women one of them told me are by their
very nature skirted charlatans bent on
breaking the will and sapping the
strength of the soldiers of Allah -
which Pascal whispered a little too
smugly see I told you so but now that
I'm here in Pascal's knot now that our
truck is broken down and we're cold and
miserable and walking through an endless
minefield of snow now that I cannot walk
another inch with this idiotic rayon
cloth over my head what are they gonna
do take me back to the shower punish me
for not wearing it and then suddenly an
amazing thing happens one of the soldier
walks over hands me his pockle for my
head
another gives me one of his brown
shoulder blankets to hide the
Kalashnikov then Hashim looking slightly
defeated takes a thick cotton scarf and
ties it around my neck and mouth so no
one will be able to tell that I don't
have a beard I have one it's a small
victory but I have one I am for the
moment a man a tiny happy bleeding man
by nightfall we finally reach a cave
it's a large cave a furnished cave
actually with a pot-bellied stove a
couple of heroic-looking framed
portraits of various Islamic men hung
somehow from the stone wall some
kerosene lamps a black metal pot a tin
tray with a whole stack of glass cups
for tea a few stacks of tin bowls a
wooden box of tin spoons and a large gun
rack to hold all the kalashnikovs the
Mujahideen step inside lay down their
brown blankets on the cold earth face
Mecca and for the fourth time today
begin to pray bismillah al Rahim Oh
Rahim in the name of the God the
beneficent the merciful knees bend hands
palm and palm worry beads dangling
and pom worry beads dangling bodies up
bodies down bodies prostrated to Allah
blessed be he before leaving for shower
Hashim had asked me if I were a
Christian when I told him I was a Jew
his face tensed and he said it would be
best if I died I did not admit this to
any of the other Mucha Deen they know
like Jew he said oh yeah well get in
line I said but when he looked at me
quizzically I said no problem our secret
then as an extra precaution arey measure
he insisted on teaching me the first
line of the Quran along with the Kalima
the profession of faith suggesting I
mouthed the words along with the
Mujahideen when they pray la ilaha
illallah muhammad rasool allah there is
no god but Allah and Muhammad is His
Prophet the men continue and I dutifully
move my mouth in unison apparently if
you can recite that one line of the
Kalima you can be considered a Muslim a
snap as conversions go unfortunately I
find that every time the Mujahideen pray
it triggers the Hebrew tune he named my
tove to pop into my head which competes
with my mouths ability to recite the
Islamic prayers probably some ancient
Hebraic defense mechanism wired into my
genetic code another band of Mujahideen
same Shiite group the ha ducati Islam II
have stopped here - for the night they
have a fire going underneath the metal
pot and four of them are sitting around
it's during its greasy gluttonous
contents with makeshift spoons pausing
periodically to puff on their Winston's
what is it I asked Kashi fat he says
from mutton
i faint excitement oh I say great it
must be either from this VAT or from the
tea water that I can track the amoebic
dysentery that will dog me for the next
few months as blithely as blissfully
unaware of the single-celled creatures
swimming around my food as they are of
me i slurp up the steaming fat with the
rest of the men sitting cramped together
in our cave our new home
dipping and freshly baked naan and
drinking glass after glass of sugary tea
feeling the warm liquid slide down my
esophagus and into my cold empty stomach
life is good I think to myself I'm not
frozen I have shelter bread and a boar
bowl full of warm fat I can handle this
after dinner the men spread out their
black brown blankets and I unroll my
very expensive life blue French down
sleeping bag tested in the cold of the
Alps and prepare for slumber some of the
men huddled together for warmth little
puffs of steam emerge from our mouths if
I'm a bit concerned about being the only
woman in a cave full of men I try not to
show it besides these are Islamic
warriors most with wives and families
back in Peshawar were they to commit
adultery with me the prescribed penalty
would be death this is a comforting
thought one of the Mujahideen Tunes is
Radio 2 the push to version of the BBC
and though I can't understand a word of
this evening's report the familiar regal
horns that usher in the hourly news is
unexpectedly soothing like a lullaby the
voice from the radio begins suddenly
some of the men sit bolt upright then
more a few men start to speak angrily
gesticulating wildly two are laughing
soon all the Mujahideen are sitting up
guys what's going on I strained to
understand anything being said and
suddenly I catch a familiar refrain blah
blah blah Salman Rushdie blah blah blah
blah Salman Rushdie blah blah Rushdie
blah blah blah mmm I know Salman Rushdie
is a writer but why is a book review
leading the top of the BBC I took on how
she was jacket but he shoves me away Shh
he says must listen then after a minute
or so he says ah miss Debra its book
book Salman Rushdie he write a very bad
book so no one will buy it I think
what's the big deal a lively discussion
is now Rupp ting all over the cave the
men grabbed their Kalashnikovs what the
hell is going on sorry I say I don't
understand uh miss Deborah Salman
Rushdie write bad book bad for Allah not
nice to Allah bad bad to Allah we
Muslim must kill him and with that
Hashim and his band of crazy warriors of
Islam run out of the cave into the cold
darkness where they proceeded to shoot
up hundreds of rounds of ammunition into
the starry night sky
yelling allah akbar allah akbar god is
great god is great each vowing to kill
salman rushdie should the unfortunate
writer stroll through our cave in our
nameless mountains somewhere in
afghanistan i follow them outside but
now Hashim tells me they're yelling down
with America down with America and I
start second-guessing my decision to be
out here amid the frenzied delirium I
try explaining tashi met Salman Rushdie
is either British or Indian depending on
your cultural bent but he's certainly
not American that in any case were we
Americans funding this war of theirs
anyway we donate stingers to your jihad
I remarked but a writer an anglo-indian
writer at that insults allah and now you
want to kill americans am I missing
something here the noise of the bullets
is deafening I feel a little ill I make
my way back into the cave and suddenly
I'm barfing semi digested mutton fat all
over my fancy blue sleeping bag
that's all I read from the first chapter
and turns out ok don't worry this
afterward is actually a second afterward
the first afterward I wrote as an homage
to my friend Maya and she's here tonight
where's Maya hello Maya
anyway Maya was the first person to say
to me you should write a book and I said
I can't write a book I don't have any
place to write it and she said well I'm
at work during the day and you can use
my apartment which is the most generous
offer I've ever received in my entire
life and I thank her dearly for it every
day and she even left lemonade in the
fridge for me most days and tea you know
she's British so she leaves a lot of tea
and you know Virginia Woolf wrote a Room
of One's Own and a woman needs a Room of
One's Own if she's going to write and
this is
true you need to have the space and the
quiet if you're going to be able to
write anything I had two toddlers at the
time of two and a one-year-old and there
was just no way in our tiny two-bedroom
apartment that I was going to find the
quiet I needed and so Thank You Maya
once again and if you'd like to read
that afterward you may read it
this is the afterword to the afterword
the first afterword was written in July
and this one is written September 23rd
2001 what a difference two months make I
wrote the passage above during the
middle of my reel and our country's
metaphorical summer but this is a book
about a girl who goes off to war and
comes back home where it's safe which
already seems like a quaint but
misguided relic of an ancient more
innocent era home safe not anymore
hence here's an afterword to the
afterward I couldn't not write it on the
morning of September 11th 2001 my now
four-year-old daughter Sasha watched the
Twin Towers of the World Trade Center
burn from the windows in our living room
she asked me with a quivering lip who
would adopt the children of all the dead
mommies and daddies
I watched the plume rise the smoke
thickened and I cursed the men who did
it I cursed the man who did it because
even in those early hours we could all
read his fingerprints I tried to lead
Sasha away from the window
but she's her mother's daughter she
wanted to go to the roof to get a better
view we went up I shot a few pictures
the only ones that would take all week
self conscious souvenirs of the day I
knew would slice time into two segments
before and after I had an instant
flashback to the MU J teen streaming out
of our cave in Afghanistan on the night
of the Rushdie fatwa down with America
they'd shouted the hate the hate even
then we should have known down with
America down with America indeed the
towers collapsed one by one screams
echoed in the street down with our sense
of safety
however illusory down with our optimism
our goofy hope our sheltered innocence
our purple mountain melt
potted rockets red glare sanctuary down
with down with I was suddenly choked by
a single thought a thought so seemingly
demented I wished I weren't having it
America I thought has been raped I tried
to push the image aside try to focus on
facts Islamic terrorists thousands dead
for planes bush and hiding instead of
metaphor but the image stuck I once read
that a soldier's reaction to war and a
woman's reaction to rape are
psychologically one in the same and if
you walked around New York City on the
days following the attacks you might
have said we were all soldiers and women
suffering from post-traumatic stress
stripped of our emotional shields
reduced to intermittently sobbing
zombies we were skittish seeing every
plane in the sky as a potential
aggressor we were frightened regarding
the minutiae of our environment in a new
and scary light we were distracted
craving order in a world of chaos and
constantly like an endless loop in the
back of our minds played the image of
the moment of penetration this
playground safe should I be drinking
this water is there a bomb in that
backpack what he was killed she's
missing plane and tower plane and tower
stop crying
be strong give blood clean out closet
plane and tower organized must be
organized tidy rows sorted socks control
get back to work sit down and write ha
plane in tower keep a normal schedule
kids to school breakfast lunch dinner
work work what I forgot to pick up
Sasha's friends from preschool Jesus a
poster in the subway have you seen my
daddy
more tears plane and tower plane and
tower plane in tower when the Taliban
came to power in Afghanistan they
immediately smashed all television sets
I'm not a big fan of Baywatch either nor
am i proud of it is an export of our
culture nor am i blind to reasons why it
might offend the sensibilities of even a
secular Muslim but let's not forget that
on the eve of their murderous suicidal
rampage some of the terrorists spent
their last precious hours of life in a
Florida strip club
let's not forget
in return for their martyrdom they were
promised an afterlife spent frolicking
with 72 virgins let's not forget that
despite this conception of paradise as a
cloud full of willing virgins what these
terrorists actually want here on earth
is a sexless paradise populated with
burqa clad uneducated domestically
enslaved women America's been raped for
what her brazenness her mere existence
America has been raped and like all
victims of violent assault she will
never be the same but but dare I say
this it's only been a week and a half
since the attack way too early for
hindsight you will be reading this many
months hence who knows what will
transpire between now and then but
knowing what I think I know about the
aftermath of violence knowing what I
think I know about the resilience of the
human spirit in the face of evil and
adversity I will say it
I am hopeful about our future
yes we've under Dan unthinkable trauma
yes we can no longer afford to take our
safety for granted but just as a woman
who's been attacked is able to learn
sooner or later not to see every man as
a potential threat just as a soldier
haunted by nightmares of severed limbs
is able to reintegrate sooner or later
into civilian life our country will come
back from this trauma not only in good
health but perhaps stronger wiser and
with a greater appreciation of life for
having endured it I can already see the
phoenix rising even now with the smoke
still rising downtown out of the ashes I
have seen strangers hugging each other
standing ovations for firemen and blood
donation queue stretching several city
blocks on the formerly indifferent
streets of New York I've seen in America
shocked out of its navel-gazing
and forced into pondering the people and
events outside its previously safe
borders how many Americans knew were
Afghanistan was on the map before
September 11th 2001 how many know now
I've seen the American right slap Jerry
Falwell on the wrist for daring to
speculate that we and excuse me here for
bringing back the rape metaphor but it's
act
we're asking for it here with his actual
words the abortionist have gotta bear
some burden for this because God will
not be mocked and when we destroy 40
million little innocent babies we make
God mad I really believe that the pagans
and the abortionists and the feminists
and the gays and the lesbians who are
actively trying to make that an
alternative lifestyle
the ACLU people for the American Way all
of them who've tried to secularize
America I point the finger in their face
and say you helped this happen Jerry bin
Laden Osama Falwell smashing planes into
towers blowing up abortion clinics
what's the difference really other than
scope intolerance by any name can no
longer be tolerated and even if the more
moral majority has been shocked into
some small comprehension of this notion
well then I call that a move in the
right direction it is the Friday night
after the attack on the World Trade
Center my husband and I gather the kids
together and walk with Him the six
blocks to our local synagogue for
Shabbat services or bacon eating barely
practicing Jews but like many secular
Americans this week were stunned by the
perversion of religion into murder
we are aching ironically for a bit of
God and community the kids Paul asleep
in our laps during the service so we
decide to take a cab home we slide
across the back seat and I noticed that
the drivers name is Mohammed I glanced
over at Paul realized realize he's
forgotten to remove his yarmulke after
services uh-oh I think I'm uneasy I
squirm I'm racked by cognitive
dissonance thinking about what Mohammed
must be thinking worth thinking about
him even if we're not thinking about how
American Muslims must now feel scared
sad angry ashamed in the wake of the
attack Mohammed pulls over to the curb
and as I hand him the fare I say to make
myself feel better to make him feel
better to make us all feel better
Salaam alaikum peace in Arabic he turns
around to face me and starts to cry
thank you he says
it is now a week after the attack
Sasha's first day of gymnastics her
actual first day was canceled when
Chelsea Piers was transformed into a
triage center so this is her new first
day she's been in our bed every night
with nightmares she complains of stomach
aches she cries a lot sometimes several
times a day lamenting the orphan
children Jacob for now seems to be
coping much better she tells me God made
a bad world because of mosquitos and
death mosquitos she asked if the plane
will smash into her apartment next but
today on her first day of gymnastics
she's finally smiling leaping high on
the trampoline turning somersaults on
the floor afterward we walk outside
together and breathe in crisp sunshine
tinged with just the slightest trace of
ash then Sasha spots the Empire State
Building to the east phew she says it's
still there funny as a New Yorker
cartoon tragic as reality America has
been raped but we're still here the
Empire State Building still stands and
for now there's solace to be found in
just standing thank you very much
Shyvana I did a reading on was it
Wednesday night if it's today yeah and I
think the best way to go about this is
if you have questions just say who it's
for if it's for both of us I'll let
chiffon go first and I'll go second and
we can all have a fun discussion here
camaraderie among female war
correspondents especially when you're
out in the field well I think there's a
lot of camaraderie period when you're
out in the field because we're under
such intense circumstances I mean I
never really felt intense competition
out there it was we were sort of all out
there trying to try to survive so there
aren't that many women out there so I
don't think that they're they're
necessarily banding together I don't
know what you're yeah when I was out
there there weren't any women to beat
camaraderie with you know for I worked
for CNN and CNN is a different animal
because it started on a shoestring
they hired a lot of women and you know
we were cheap anything with the pulse
basically and so there's overseas
especially moat maybe half of the camera
people are female so there were a lot of
women in the CNN ranks yeah you know I
will amend what I said before we had um
in Afghanistan there's a really
wonderful woman who I believe lives here
now named Donatella Lorch and she was
extremely helpful she'd been there for a
while and she just took me under her
wing gave me all four contacts and it
was really nice especially since I was
abandoned by the one person that had
promised to ensure my safety while we
were there so it was a great thing that
she did and you know I met another woman
I guess in Romania and we are still very
good friends another female
photojournalist so if there was a woman
yes the bonds became tight very quickly
this is for both of you essentially I'm
sort of wondering about the experience
as as a photo journalist or war
correspondent and the ethical ambiguity
of being a recorder
and how you negotiate that and also if
there's any sort of legal precedent that
dictates the type of behavior and when
to take the picture or when to shoot the
footage and when to help you know that's
that is one of the most difficult things
in the in the job is sticking a camera
into someone's face especially if
they've just suffered something horrible
but and it requires a lot of intuitive
response I found more often than not
when people had endured something
horrific they wanted their story told if
they'd had some terrible loss at bear at
the very least they wanted it to matter
they wanted their story told so with a
certain amount of sensitivity it usually
was okay I mean if it wasn't okay with
somebody we would I would always back
off I think it was that what you were
asking well I mean a bad way in the
moment to I mean I'm sure there's been
moments where you're recording footage
during a bombing or an attack or any
sort of violence against in other
individuals I can speak to that I there
was a time when I was in Afghanistan
where when I had to pee I had to be led
by Mujahideen off the track and what
would happen is he would walk and I
would step precisely in his footsteps he
would turn around go back to the group
and I would squat and do my business and
walk back that was the only way that it
would work because we were always
walking through minefield and one
particular day he was walking out to
lead the path for me to pee and he got
his leg blown off by a landmine and my
initial response was first fear and then
to cry
to actually go over to him to see if he
was okay because this was a man who just
got his leg blown off because he was
taking me to urinate as I was sitting
there with him trying to comfort him
until the other Mujahideen made it over
the thought did occur to me I should be
shooting this picture I should be
shooting this picture and you know I
kept thinking I've got to get my camera
out and then I just thought no I can't
do it
and I don't know if that makes me a bad
photojournalist or more female than male
or just a bad journalist but I knew in
that particular situation there was no
way I was going to stick a camera in his
face on the other hand if somebody's
dead I would shoot it and let me add one
more thing that this brings up a lot you
know going into a war zone is terrifying
it's it's really war is horrible
and I found more often than not people
were very very glad that we had gone
there and risked our lives to come there
and tell their story so I really felt
that people you know I don't can't
imagine what what happened in that
situation but I think people are happy
to have us there and do whatever they
can to help us
rules a behavior
a lawyer in the audience I don't know
what war is chaos yes thank you
actually I have two questions well one
of them is I don't know if you live
working for like a specific company or
something when you are
but just like for example I was living
in Israel this summer when all that all
those bombs when
I'm definitely interested in journalism
and I was just thinking I know that I
mean I can't imagine that you have to be
affiliated with it you know like just
how to go about doing something like
that if you care and you're interested
and my second question is this one is
like
I guess more to
or both of you really I find it really
interesting that yours when you call
Chechnya because I don't know when you
went up but I mean just like the other
day
I'm working for an organization that the
foreign minister came and he is like
saying like basically begging people to
take an interest otherwise like in a
couple years
not gonna be any tensions left and it
was just actually snapping up such
but it was just one of those things
where here you're risking your life and
it's like I kind of feel like people
that they care they don't well Chechnya
was very difficult to cover and it is
not a place that most Americans have
ever heard of or given any thought to
and that first Christmas when war break
bro caot there and I was risking my life
I mean there was a there was Christmas
can be very snow slow news time so there
was a lot of interest because of the
intensity of the footage but one day the
city was being carpet bombed and a young
American photographer was killed and the
Chechens thought it was me and they told
CNN it was me the CNN headquarters
thought I was dead for several hours
they even called my mother's phone
number but fortunately got an answer
machine and when I got back in touch
with him and and realized that all my
colleagues had been weeping for the last
few hours because I died I was horrified
and I was horrified especially because
the thought of dying in a war zone when
you know no one ever even cares I mean
that doesn't mean we should stop
covering it we've got to go out there
and cover it but there's this myth in
America that Americans don't care about
foreign news I mean if there's any any
slim silver lining with September 11th
you know Americans are maybe realizing
that we need to care about what goes on
in the rest of the world I will answer
the first question which I'll remind
everyone was this young lady was in
Israel during the summer during the
bombings and she asked was I affiliated
with any news organization and do you
necessarily have to be the rules have
changed now back then I was working for
a photo agency that was my my most basic
affiliation either with gamma or with
contact depending on what part of the my
career you're talking about
and they would I would go we would talk
together and we would decide where I was
going to go and I would pay 50% of the
cost of getting there they would pay 50%
also for the film and they would do
their best to find assignments which
would be you know a day here from time a
day there from Newsweek maybe three days
from u.s. news and who try to cobble
together so that your expenses were paid
it never worked out that way you never
had all your expenses paid you're always
constantly hemorrhaging money to pay for
your job but once you did shoot those
photos and sent them back to the photo
agency they would try to sell them and
often would sell them to various to the
magazine that you'd work for and then
they could sell them to other magazines
internationally and photojournalism is
one of those careers where you start
seeing the payoff later it's like
investing in a stock or something those
photos if that event is an event that's
going to be talked about for years to
come those pictures will be published
from years to come
I did the story on girl gangs in LA back
in 1990 and every year when I'm doing my
taxes there's just a big chunk of change
from that girl gay I don't know why
people are still interested in that
those girls from you know they're
probably older now and married or
whatever but um if photojournalist is a
very bizarre business as a business
proposition yeah if you if you want to
get your voice heard you do kind of have
to make a plan with somebody you can be
a freelance journalist and call up a
magazine or newspaper and say can I
cover this for you but if you happen to
be on the spot where news is happening
and you happen to see something and you
would write it up I would take it home
and I would just call you know all your
favorite magazines and newspapers and
say I've got this do you want it I don't
think that they would laugh at you I
think they'd say well what do you have
send it to us and
that's how would work yeah I think
there's essentially two ways to get into
if you're interested in being at foreign
correspondent there's two ways to get in
I mean you can either work your way up
the long slow tedious way in Dubuque and
and work at a local station and hope to
get get sent overseas someday or you can
do what I did and obviously what what
Deb did was go just go and because I was
interested in Russia I was just there
and initially got hired there so if you
go and choose a country that's
newsworthy and learn the language and
are there you're gonna end up being very
useful to a news organization and you
can you can move up much quicker that
way yeah when my husband and I moved to
Moscow together he was a businessman
when we moved there and he's a native
Russian speaker and within a week he was
working for ABC they just you know a
native Russian speaker and alive with
the pulse come yeah any other questions
sorry especially when you go to like
when you go to war do you have to have
some sort of protection of one of both
sides of person who's fighting the war
now how do you manage to tell the story
and personally those two like being
protective excellent so
well I'll go to Chechnya again it's very
difficult because often when you get
into a war zone especially in a civil
conflict there's a the Chechen rebels
for example really understood the power
of the press they knew they needed to
press on their side they wanted the
press on their side when we showed up
they took care of us they took us to the
frontlines they took us wherever we
wanted to go the Russians didn't get
that concept so when we try I try to go
over an interview Russians because I
wanted to tell a balanced story and
they'd shoot at her car which made it
very difficult but it didn't it but I
couldn't tell the story just from one
side so we just found ways and sometimes
it meant ditching the Chechens and just
you know barreling in there and getting
the Russians to talk to us I mean I just
think it's essential to tell both sides
in a war zone no matter how hard the
combatants are making it always trying
to sell their story that's the difficult
job of a journalist and especially when
you are with a group I mean one feels
the powerful or you see their side but
then you go to the other side you see
their side every side every war has two
sides you know nothing is black and
white no matter how we want to paint it
like that nothing in life is black and
white and so that is the job is to go
and spend time with both sides and find
a way to be impartial it's the most
important thing a correspondent
especially a war correspondent can do
that most of the workers pundits are
impartial
no I don't and you know I'll take for
example the coverage of Kosovo the CNN
had correspondents in Belgrade and very
good experienced correspondence and they
report they were sending back stories
and CNN was putting up fonts words
saying these these correspondents are
under Serbian restrictions basically
discrediting everything they were
reporting meanwhile other journalists
were out with the US military and
believe me when you're with the US
military you are under severe
restrictions but there was no such font
up no such words so I was appalled by
this so sometimes I do feel that more
and more there's this trend towards
reporting or taking sides I mean CNN is
an international news network we were
never the ethos was never our boys our
troops we were an international
objective news organization but it seems
to be you know especially since the
attack at home there's this tremendous
these tremendous feelings of patriotism
and we're forgetting sometimes that we
need to be telling all sides
what is your opinion CNN what do you
think
al-jazeera attempted to be so they
stayed there on their own CNN you're
saying that CNN Kansas has to work to
maintain an objective not our troops I
cried Afghanistan to you perfectly fine
at Al Jazeera's trying to take sth
Lancer is like mess up neutral and we're
an air of journalistic organization but
we're going to well I think you're
looking in a part at a part of the world
that does not have a tradition of Free
Press and I think al Jazeera is doing
better than many news organizations in
that part of the world and is making an
effort but I don't think that they've
necessarily reats the sophistication of
an impartial news organization that
we're talking about my first question is
having worked abroad do you see a
difference in the way that American
networks or American and journalists
cover things versus journalists from
other countries specifically because
Americans sort of pioneered the sense of
the idea of Free Press and really an
objectivity and fairness and all the
news values that I think the Brits get
it the best I really do I think if you
really want unbiased news you gotta
listen to the BBC or read the British
newspapers I do think Americans cover
the story with an American slant we are
a very isolationist country we we've
been spending 10 years thinking about
Monica and Condit and you know all these
inner workings of our own country that
really sorry don't mean a lot so I don't
even think we're used to dealing with
what's going on in the world or
interpreting it or having even the facts
at hand you've got journalists who are
have spent ten years covering Monica now
or all the sudden over in Pakistan and
have to quickly learn what's going on
over there I think that's a big problem
I think that the British and you know
the French to some extent are a little
bit better educated they've been
covering you know the international
correspondents have been all over and
have seen what's going on in the world I
agree with Deb that the British are
exceptionally good but I doesn't it
doesn't preclude some really good
American reporting but what's happened
recently is you know with a lot of
cutbacks in news organizations you're
not maintaining bureaus overseas when we
maintain a bureau overseas and you have
people that know the lay of the land and
know the language you know I I would put
my reporting from Moscow up against any
British reporters in terms of
objectivity and understanding the
country that I had that I had known and
lived in for you know 15 years and
what's happening now unfortunately
especially in the coverage of the war of
Afghanistan is we seem to be getting
this very sanitized
packaged news you know the war seems
acceptable somehow I don't get a sense
at the horror of the war there and
what's happening is more and more
they're sending the networks are sending
over these celebrity reporters they're
sending over the Geraldo's and the
Ashleigh Banfield who don't know the lay
of the land they don't know the language
and you know the you the US military has
been extremely restrictive which is in
their best interest of course so you
need reporters that know how to skirt
around those restrictions and get us the
real story and Americans are just as
capable of doing it but you need
Americans that are based overseas and
know the lay of the land ask you to
clarify a point do you think that that's
that this change has anything to do with
the fact that American reporters are
over there reporting a war that is you
know sort of out to avenge Americans I
do think that that's some of it there's
a difficulty detaching from that but I
also think it's a lack of experience if
you send in a reporter a domestic
reporter over who has no experience in a
place like this you're gonna get that
kind of reporting point one last
question you both have said that having
experienced this so often you come to
the same point every time which is that
what's the point do you find that now in
the aftermath you feel the need to be
sort of activists for peace or that you
feel like you have solutions that you
want to impart it's a as a journalist
you're not supposed to be an activist
it's kind of you're supposed to keep
those separate I just had an experience
with my son where he's in his
first-grade class and they the teacher
asked the kids to bring in a dollar for
the Afghani refugees after Bush got on
TV and said each American child should
bring in a dollar and all of a sudden
this little class project became
controversial within the school with one
mother saying to another mother why are
we raising money for Afghani refugees
isn't that like raising money for the
enemy this is a well-educated liberal
school and yet they didn't really get it
and
I was so angry about that kind of
reaction at that kind of blinded
reaction that I said to the teacher if I
can figure out a way to bring that money
over there
with Jacob would you allow that to
happen she said of course so Oprah
Magazine Thank You Oprah funded our trip
mmm and we went over with a check and
with a lot of school supplies and with
power bars and toys and we went over and
for 10 days we played Santa Claus and we
brought stuff to schools and to refugee
camps so it's the only time I've
actually ever done something
quote/unquote activist but it didn't
feel activist so much as a necessity at
that moment in time
you know we live in New York it was a
month after the attacks these people
these parents of these kids still
couldn't get it and I just thought I'm
going to show what war does to you know
the victims of wars are always women and
children and I went over with my child
mother to mother child to child just to
say hey we are thinking about you yeah I
don't I don't consider myself a
journalist anymore I'm now a recovering
and as Deb says we're not supposed to be
activists but I saw enough horror and I
saw what war does and I don't think it
works and I do feel I'm now studying
psychology and I've always been
interested in conflict resolution so I
can see myself in the future my book
talks a lot about how war doesn't work
on many levels and how conflict doesn't
work and how it needs to be resolved so
I can see myself being an advocate
against war because of what I've seen
over the years
when you were there what's happened
short of our doing what we're doing
what do you think could have been any
answers
so far out of control
what are you instead of bombing them I
don't know I mean I thought maybe from
being in the inside see I think you're
dealing with an incredibly complicated
terrain you're dealing with tribes that
have hated each other forever
and even when I was there and the common
enemy was the Soviets they still were
beating each other up and there's a
really there's a very interesting
Afghani game called booth Kashi and in
boos Kashi you have two teams of Afghani
men and they're on horses and their
object is to get this goat this headless
goat from one end of the field to the
other end of the field from the impure
circle into the pure circle and you're
supposed to be working on teams like
polo and you're supposed to drag the
goat from the horse and get it into the
circle and then you score a point well
what they do in boosts Kashi is that
instead of the team winning money for
winning the point
whoever whichever Mujahideen actually
scores the point he gets the money and
the team members don't get the prize
money so what happens it's like the
perfect metaphor for Afghanistan it
devolves into a free-for-all with every
man for himself trying to get that goat
into the circle and you know if you
think about it that is what's been going
on in Afghanistan for a long time I I
hope and pray that that will change I'm
not too optimistic I don't know what
other people feel but it just seems like
a really crazy place and yes we got rid
of the Taliban but who's next which
broof is going to come up next yeah I'm
not I'm not sure that bombing
Afghanistan he's gonna do much more than
make us feel better that we went out and
kicked but but because I think it's very
hard to discern what's really going on
there from the coverage and I don't
think that it's gonna be over anytime
soon and you know unless we really
address some of the underlying issues of
rage that breed Osama bin Laden's you
know getting rid of one doesn't tend
more spread up in their place so I think
that it's far more complex
than just going and bombing the hell out
of a country
hundreds and hundreds of thousands
yes that is given to us the average
citizen of media how are you supposed to
ascertain what the scene is not really
happy
Americans are generally leaving out as
educated about what's happening around
the world but when you slide become
educators there's
it's a very difficult even to get the
information as you just stated
what's going on I have three letters for
you NP R well I have size 5 you know 6
New York Times I think I mean I think
you're gonna do much better with the New
York Times and watching MSNBC you know
television some of your at 40 at times
was contradictory to the general
mainstream for administration and you
could not get it through you know CNN is
such a monolith and it's you know this
big 24 hour animal that needed to be fed
so I often reported views that weren't
mainstream I mean I went to Croatia when
I was based in Moscow and I went to
cover the Balkan conflict and I covered
serve villages that serves that have
been driven out of their homes by
Croatians
not something went off and saw on the
television but CNN being the sort of big
monolith I mean they did you know they
ran it I mean they saw me up there I
sent a piece it aired and and I really
never felt they did they did trust their
people in the field generally and I
never felt that my stories were edited
or or not shown or censored it was that
that instance during Kosovo where where
I had a problems I think the reporters
were being discredited but generally and
that this was back a few years ago I
don't I don't know what to say about the
organization today I was just gonna
speak of a specific example of that
which is when I was in Romania covering
the post chess coup ruins and the
elections
I had a Romanian boyfriend and he said
you know there are so many journalists
here let's go find another story I have
a story that I'd like to check out he'd
heard about these Romanian orphanages
and he said we should go try to find
them and we did we spent days circling
around the country and we found volter
st this orphanage there and it was as
horrible as you remember the pictures
being and we took pictures of this came
back to Bucharest sent the pictures back
to Paris where my photo agency was and
never heard back from them and a week
went by and I called my boss and it
would take you know an hour and a half
to get a call through so I called him
and I said so whatever happened with
those orphanage pictures is a really
important story you need to get it out
there and he said hey you know you're
supposed to be covering the elections
you're supposed to be covering what's
going on in the streets you're not
supposed to be covering orphanages and I
said are you kidding me you know this is
an important story and it was just
amazing to me that they were sitting on
something like that but yet there was
nothing I could do you know it took an
hour and a half to get a phone call
through I was you know in Bucharest I
couldn't go to the magazines myself the
agent was supposed to be my voice my
representative in Paris to sell the
pictures and in the end result I ended
up just handing the story to a
photographer that was on assignment for
the New York Times thinking well at
least he'll get it out there so yeah
there's been times where I've shot a
story which I thought this needs to be
seen and it wasn't seen oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah sure yeah Jim Nachtwey shot
the photos it was a New York Times
Magazine and that's when all the
hullabaloo started
they're two different animals completely
I mean CNN International I mean it same
correspondents generally but CNN
International is much more international
in its scope a far better news
organization if you ask me unfortunately
domestic CNN is trying to compete for
ratings with people like Fox and MSNBC
and and the old ethos of CNN when Ted
Turner started it was that the news is
the star they didn't care what the
anchors and the reporters look like how
bedraggled we were it was about getting
the story and now as they're trying to
compete and have become corporately
owned and they care so much about the
bottom line that's changing and new you
know stars are the issue not the news
but so far CNN International still
somewhat immune to that
I don't know maybe the internet but not
in terms of other stations unfortunately
CNN's the last bastion bastion who was
sort of the most responsible for biasing
news and producers and editors or is it
the journalist or was it both or I mean
I just sort of heard about the story of
your agent but when we talk about there
there's a stilted you know I think
there's this idea that there's this big
conspiracy out there but a news a giant
news organization is a chaotic and
unruly thing I mean there isn't a
mindset we're gonna we're gonna get this
view point across or we're gonna it's
it's a whole combination of things
and some of it's laziness some of its
lack of really getting out in the rest
of the world and and understanding it's
just all so it's just reacting I mean
news organizations are totally reactive
seat-of-the-pants
split-second decisions and it's also we
bring whoever we are to our stories we
are the filters through whom you see
news so whatever our personal biases or
psychological baggage is we are bringing
that to the story so you have all these
human filters to get through it's not a
giant computer conspiracy it's sort of
accidental bumbling if you ask me and
the other thing to remember about TV
especially you know the big networks the
executive producers of these show have
ratings and they can see minute by
minute how the ratings go so they can
see Oh in this story where we added a
scientific fact people stopped watching
and turn it off so a lot of the times
when I was working at Dateline you'd
have a story a scientific story and then
they would just kind of cleanse it of
all facts and you know at a certain
point you say well you know what's going
on in and there really is a dumbing down
and an assumption of idiocy on the part
of the viewer that's you know is
frustrating as a journalist to be
dealing with that but it's the viewer
you know it's driven by viewer reaction
and they see that stove we're doing a
story on you know something scientific
and a little bit difficult and people
are turning their TVs off and go on and
watch you know Raymond or whatever the
new show is but so that's that's hard
but I do feel that it's essential I mean
that if the American public if you do
tell them a good story they will come
they will listen you know if it's the
story of a New Jersey mobster you know
we're all watching it's about telling a
good story and it doesn't matter if it's
Timbuktu or Detroit as journalists it's
essential to tell people a story so they
can understand and have interest yeah
generally all right one more all right
I recently in the net started reading
through the air gun and adjourned the
beginnings the stuff you don't know
urban and history all those are the
early gangs the Zionist pre Israel gangs
that bludgeoned and murdered control
Arabs out of their homes using a lot of
Nazi tactics and I'm amazed at how much
is in the net you can pull up on them
and I've made copies of everything
around people also the Mossad there's a
tremendous amount of information on the
Mossad the holy men who don't exist
neither encounters
and what is happening to Palestinians
and to Arabs and all's we're hearing
about is how vicious and on murders they
are in a distortion and and I'm stunned
that nobody is bringing us out I'm
weaving through legitimate alone and
there are photographs of children of
care various ages have been gunned down
by the Israelis who have logged bombs so
small ways type stun bombs into
playgrounds where the kids that are some
of the things that are going on the
little boy that was searching year old
boy that was photographed in front of an
Israeli tank they didn't touch him none
because journalists weren't there a few
days later Israelis gun to kid down he's
a martyr so there's so much going on out
there that isn't getting and I don't
know why so we're hearing about Monica
kind of the rest of them and now of
course about Afghanistan because there's
a terrible long history of Arab
frustration we have so badly treated to
the entire concept of the Arabs and
sucked up to Israel that it's appalling
and I don't know why there isn't more
out about I'm getting in through this
stuff but there's a great deal of
information on the net Mossad mega
stories photographs row after row of
covers little ones movement shot and
gunned down at reiden I don't understand
why that isn't more in the public eye I
guess we're too busy following up
Hollywood celebrities and as you say the
names in the press and my early friends
in the 50s were all united pressed and
they Pete Robinson covered Algeria he
was the only American in fact the only
person who's the Christ who would go
through I guess I basically say why
aren't we hearing about this we're not
hearing about a lot of things out there
you know that's part of can I tell you
about a really dirty little secret in
the news business
I mean yeah there's depth says there's a
lot of things we're not hearing about
especially in Africa and the way it
often worked was there's a there's an
equation one dead American equals Ted
10 dead Europeans equals 10,000 dead
Africans and unfortunately that's that's
the truth of it well if you know one
person in your neighborhood dies then
that trumps 10,000 Colombians who died
in a mudslide or something can we have
one okay one more I just wanted to say
I'm regarding what you're talking about
like in terms of getting stuff in the
media and you know how do you know who's
right who's wrong blah blah blah and I
just found it interesting you know
regarding her point of view first with
the arab-israeli conflict because you
know I think that just goes back where
it's like when you you also have to see
where obviously so many people have been
killed I could you obviously you have to
look at every different aspect but you
know where you're getting your
information and not every death is
reported but y'all have to agree before
you can dig up dirt on every side
anywhere it depends you know often as
journalists we walk in in the middle of
the story and we forget what happened
yesterday or 10 years ago
so there is whatever side you look at in
any of these conflicts there's all kinds
of dirt that you can dig up
Siobhan Darrow as author of flirting
with danger confessions of a reluctant
war reporter Deborah kopaka and Cogan is
author of shudder babe adventures in
love and war they're published by anchor
books an imprint of Random House visit
Random House comm slash anchor for more
information